- [Kelly] Hello!
- Hello!
Look at this lovely audience.
- I know, I'm so sorry, though,
I'm not there to like hug
you in person and say hello.
Thank you so much for being here.
- Thank you for having me.
(audience claps and cheers)
- I know, like, I wanna,
like, hug the monitor
and get my arms around you.
- (laughs) Just do it. Just kidding.
- Yeah. I'll just, ah. Kiss,
kiss, kiss, kiss, kiss.
- Have you ever met Jewel?
Have y'all ever met?
- No, we have not met, but I
was admiring her beautiful,
festive, green dress.
- Aww.
- You as well, we look
like Christmas ornaments.
- I know, I'm, I'm
saying I'm Hanukkah chic.
- (laughs) Well Andrea,
I hear that you have a
teenage daughter at home.
- I do.
- [Kelly] I'm praying for you right now.
How's that going?
- Yeah. I'll take all
your hopes and prayers.
She's 13 and I keep waiting
for the other shoe to drop
and she's actually a really
good, a really good kid.
Which is fantastic. I'm very lucky.
I will so, will say, though, comedically,
having younger kids is a lot more fun.
Like, they give you a lot more fodder
for talking about stuff. Like
right now, all I can say is
"Oh, one word answers?
I guess that's fun."
You know. But when my daughter was little,
you know it's her not
enjoying your pubic hair
and like other weird,
innocent things that happen.
You know where they're like,
"Am I getting that? I don't want it."
And you're like, okay, well
this is best case scenario
so get on board. Yeah, this is...
- [Kelly] But it is funny though.
My six year old, it's so funny.
My, my eight year old's very talkative.
My six year old is a one word guy.
I, takes forever, he's like a vault.
He just never, I'm like,
how are you my kid?
I talk so much. I don't
know. He just doesn't talk.
- That's probably why.
- No, you know what it is. It's not me,
it's my daughter 'cause
she's a mini-me, so (laughs)
- He can't get a word in,
so he's just givin' up.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Andrea] Yeah.
- [Kelly] But Andrea, tell us a little
about "Tulsa King" and your character.
- So "Tulsa King" is a
drama and I play opposite
this new up and coming
actor, Sylvester Stallone.
(audience claps)
I think he, I think he's got something,
I feel like he's got a something
that might get him there.
And basically it's a story
about, he's a mobster,
he's been in jail for 25 years.
He comes out of jail,
thinks he's gonna go back
to his New York mobster
family, and basically
the world has moved on from him
and they don't need him there anymore,
and they send him to Oklahoma.
And he now is creating
sort of a new world there.
I'm an ATF agent who has
like a chemistry with him.
We, and we start kind of
having a night together.
I don't realize how much
older he is than me.
I find out, I'm like, "oh
(beeps) God, I gotta get out."
- His pubic hair is his gray.
(audience laughs)
Sorry
- Now who's, then we come to pubic hair.
- And now I'm gone, I'm lost, I'm gone.
- My work here is done.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
I can't wait to promote
this specific episode.
- I feel like I've brought this show down.
- Just edit me out. Like this is...
- I know, I've taken,
- It's all, it's all good.
- The sweetest woman that's ever been
and, and brought her down. By the way,
we all have pubic hair.
There's nothing, Let's,
it's not dirty. That's what
I had to tell my daughter.
- [Jewel] Unless you're from the nineties.
Nobody has any pubic hair left.
- [Andrea] Yeah, that
is true, that is true.
- It's all, it's all gone.
- It's all gone.
And so, basically he's creating
a new sort of mob world.
It's a little fish outta water.
It's, he's amazing in the show.
And you know, we have this push and pull.
We're both kind of very lonely people
who've been thrown into Oklahoma,
don't have a lot of
intimacy or connections.
I'm ATF. He's a mobster.
Not a great combo moving
forward in that way.
- [Kelly] Ooh. But probably great tension.
- But, but there's some good tension and
some good stuff. It was really fun.
- I love tension.
(Andrea laughs)
So Andrea, so did, it's just
wonderful. It's wonderful.
So did you do any like
firearm training for this?
- I did. You know, basically
you step out of your door
and you're in a firing
range, I assume in Oklahoma.
(Kelly laughs)
But no, I did, I went to
the range a, a couple times
and I, you know, shot multiple guns.
I wanted to, you know, really do, you know
look like I knew what I
was doing and that I wasn't
not the first time holding
guns, and it was fantastic.
And I, I will say, I
realized I'm not a great shot
but I'm more like, "here's a warning."
I'm not, you're not
gonna get hurt that bad.
But maybe move out of the way
'cause it still won't be fun
but you're not gonna
die. That's how I shoot.
Like, you get the little
guy with the picture
and it's kind of all around,
but your heart is fine.